haciendo el peligroso viaje a través del
canal de la mancha desde francia hasta
el reino unido- estos migrantes están
dando un paso muy arriesgado en la
búsqueda de una mejor vida muchas
personas tienen familiares con quienes
quieren estar con quienes se sienten
seguros por lo que quieren solicitar
asilo en el reino unido- con su familia
y otras personas simplemente no han
podido ingresar de manera segura al
sistema en otros lugares si miras en el
norte de francia ves un gran número de
personas que no pueden ingresar al
sistema francés viven en la miseria
absolutamente desesperados así que por
supuesto que quieren probar en algún
lugar donde esperan estar a salvo el
lunes casi 1300 personas cruzaron el
canal estableciendo un nuevo récord en
24 horas el número de personas que
realizan el viaje en lo que va del año
casi se ha duplicado en comparación con
el punto equivalente en 2021 de 12.500
el año pasado a 22.600 en la actualidad
esas últimas cifras se producen a pesar
de las políticas cada vez más agresivas
para frenar las cifras
y el gobierno británico lanzó un
controvertido programa para enviar
solicitantes de asilo a ruanda donde se
procesarán sus solicitudes pero el
primer vuelo de junio fue cancelado tras
un fallo del tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos el reino unido- también
ha financiado la vigilancia costera
adicional en francia pero los políticos
de ambos lados del canal se han
criticado mutuamente por no hacer lo
suficiente para detener los cruces el
gobierno ha dicho que seguirá
retrocediendo pero para aquellos que
hacen estos viajes riesgosos la promesa
de un mejor futuro es más fuerte